les apiculteurs du sud ouest de la
france sont satisfaits après deux ans en
quête un juge du lot et garonne vient
d'interdire un insecticide le région ce
produit serait à l'origine de la
surmortalité des abeilles
l'entreprise qui fabrique cet
insecticide et son pdg sont mises en
examen
basf agro a décidé de faire appel
nicolas lisez le régent ts est un
insecticide utilisé au stade de la
plantation
les graines sont enrobées ceux qui
protègent les cultures pendant toute la
croissance au moment de la floraison
l'insecticide et censés avoir disparu
mais pour les apiculteurs c'est bien
cette substance qui est à l'origine de
la mort de milliers d'abeilles 2500
colonies décimé en un an
en midi pyrénées après deux ans
d'enquêté à saint gaudens le juge guari
vient de suspendre la commercialisation
de l'insecticide la société basf et son
dirigeant sont mises en examen pour mise
en vente de produits agricoles toxiques
nuisibles à la santé de l'homme et de
l'animal
l'entreprise l'un des leaders mondiaux
du secteur rejette l'accusation
je vais me battre contre la mort du
régent tout simplement parce que
l'ensemble des éléments factuels qui
sont entre nos mains
s'ils ont été construits par des
techniciens par toute une série de
services techniques ou autres
eh bien on démontré l'innocuité de ce
produit sur les abeilles
l'interdiction du régent ts était très
attendue par les apiculteurs qui
dénonçait la nocivité de l'insecticide
depuis des années en 2002 ce couple a
perdu 80% de ses abeilles et pour eux
l'insecticide a même eu un impact sur
leur propre santé on a eu une éruption
de boutons et gonflement des nausées
et ça a duré une huitaine de jours
alors les professionnels veulent
maintenant aller encore plus loin au
bout de dix années à voir cette première
victoire parce que son étude c'est une
grosse bouffée d'espoir pour nous on
espère que ça va pas s'arrêter là parce
que on sait pertinemment bien qu'il y en
ad'autres d'autres molécules à venir et
qui seront sur le terrain et d'autres
qui sont dans les tiroirs
d'autres insecticides comme le gaucho
fabriqués par bailleurs les apiculteurs
l'accusent également de tué leurs
abeilles et ils demandent ce soir qu'il
soit retiré de la vente après la
suspension commercial du régent ts le
régent ts qui ne disposait d'ailleurs
que d'une autorisation provisoire de
vente une autorisation renouvelée chaque
année par le ministère de l'agriculture